[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous mardi à 20 mars bienvenue
dans le 7-8 journal sur tv 78 tout de
suite les titres de cette édition
c'est en ce moment mars bleu le mois de
sensibilisation au cancer colorectal
plus de 40 mille nouveaux cas sont
découverts chaque année en france mais
un dépistage précoce facilite la
guérison est la cpam des yvelines et
deux autres associations organisé hier
lundi une journée de prévention ludique
sur la maladie montrer l'apport des
entreprises du secteur à la création de
richesses et d'emplois c'est l'ambition
de la semaine de l'artisanat qui se
déroule jusqu'à vendredi un événement
national décliné dans le département
hier la chambre de métiers de
l'artisanat des yvelines remettait ses
médailles et diplômes nous recevons son
président ronan keraudran et puis notre
portrait de la semaine s'intéresse à un
habitant des clayes sous bois après un
burn-out frédéric pellerin a décidé de
changer de voie professionnelle pour se
consacrer aux autres il a créé son
entreprise d aide à la personne à nous
l'avons rencontré autres invités de ce
journal anissa tamini ambassadrice du
premier festival rire soleil est un
festival d'humour au programme ce
week-end dans les yvelines c'est à
suivre dans ce journal
ce chiffre pour débuter 2,2 environ 2,2
millions d'euros récoltés pour le
téléthon 2010 est dans les yvelines et
les chiffres définitifs de l'opération
solidaire ont été dévoilés ce mardi et
les yvelines se place deuxième derrière
paris dans les départements franciliens
les plus donateurs plus de 14 millions
d'euros ont été collectés au niveau
régional rappelez-vous sur le territoire
beaucoup de défis à relever pour cette
édition du téléthon dont ce record du
monde dans dix à cabreira davilla à
saint-cyr-l'ecole 24 heures de nage en
apnée pour la bonne cause une journée
d'information sur le dépistage du cancer
colorectal elle se tenait yava lundi à
versailles à l'occasion de mars bleu
c'est le mois de sensibilisation sur la
pathologie
un événement orchestré par la ceppm d
en partenariat avec la ligue contre le
cancer et l'association de dépistage de
masse organisées le rendez vous se
voulait ludique un reportage de nicolas
landry et mickaël millero le côlon tour
une visite guidée d'un côlon géant
devant la caisse primaire d'assurance
maladie des yvelines
une structure gonflable pour informer
les visiteurs sur le cancer colorectal
une pathologie formés à travers des
polypes des tumeur bénigne vous avez un
polype qui est très grand avec une
excroissance qui est vraiment retirer
alors vous avez plusieurs stades soit
vous avez une excroissance qui vient
bien à l'intérieur du polype fin du
côlon pardon soit vous avez un polype
qui reste bien bien ancrée sur la paroi
de l'intestin
on n'a pas l'habitude vraiment de se
promener dans un colon et en même temps
ça permet de de valère d'avoir des
informations de discuter d'avoir des
renseignements et puis finalement
d'enlever toute peur par rapport aux
tests
justement ce que j'ai appris aujourd'hui
c'est que neuf cancers sur 10 peuvent
être justement
je dirais
geri entre guillemets si on le prend
assez tôt donc du coup c'est important
de relayer cette information
une initiative organisée avec la ligue
contre le cancer et les demis des
associations engagées dans la promotion
du dépistage auprès des yvelinois entre
50 et 74 ans alors que 43 mille
personnes sont diagnostiquées atteints
du cancer du côlon chaque année c'est
important parce que ça évite de
développer des pathologies qui peuvent
être lourdes et compliquées
voilà donc c'est en amont et voilà c'est
important en emportant con qu'on doit
très vite et ce qui était important
c'est de pouvoir créer un événement
ludique visuel avec du partage des
échanges pour dédramatiser cette maladie
et ce dépistage
selon les données de la demie près de
100000 hibino ans participent au
dépistage entre juin 2015 et mai 2010
est jusqu'à vendredi c'est la semaine
nationale de l'artisanat événement pour
mettre en avant le secteur qui
représente 1,3 million d'entreprises en
france un événement qui se décline dans
le département d'en parler avec à notre
invité renom keraudren bonsoir bonsoir
vous êtes le président de la chambre de
métiers de l'artisanat des yvelines elle
propose divers événements au cours de
cette semaine on va en parler dans un
instant alors point d'orgue d'abord de
cette semaine c'était hier lundi à
l'hôtel de ville de versailles vous avez
remis vos médailles et diplômes aux
apprentis méritants et aux artisans
pourquoi est il important de les
valoriser ces apprentis et ses artisans
je dirais que nous avons des semaines de
tous nous avons des semaine du goût nous
avons des semaines du pneu actuellement
et
l'assemblée permanente des chambres de
métiers a décidé que fallait mettre en
avant comme tous nos artisans
donc au niveau national effectivement
nous avons cette semaine de l'artisan et
donc nous avons félicités hier des
artisans des conjoints collaborateurs et
des compagnons ils étaient au nombre de
60 entre médaille de bronze médaille
d'argent et médaille d'or en fonction de
leur ancienneté de leur implication au
sein du métier leur conscience
professionnelle voilà et donc c'est
quand même important de on ne parle pas
suffisamment 2 nous sommes des petites
fourmis laborieuses et on n'a pas le
temps de s'arrêter on n'a pas le temps
de passer sur les plateaux télévisés et
donc là on fait on fait quelque chose il
faut mettre en avant cet incident et
artisanale en sion revient sur la soirée
et sur ce qu'il faut en retenir est la
récompense on l'a dit des apprentis
méritants qui étaient répartis sur deux
pôles
c'est ça ces apprentis méritants non les
apprentis méritants ce sont
effectivement les apprentis que nous
avons notre cfa qui en fin de compte
plusieurs nous avons plusieurs corps de
métiers du boucher le boulanger
coiffure esthétique donc tout le monde y
est passé si je puis dire papac deux
poêles plusieurs plusieurs fois
récompensé vous avez également distingué
à 54 chefs d'entreprise de l'artisanat
pourquoi les récompenser eux c'est comme
je vous le disais c'est le côté
conscience conscience professionnelle
écoute du client savoir de conseillers
aussi un client potentiel
le respect donc tout ça ce sont des
petites choses qui font des petits plus
et qui font que à la finale l'artisanat
une belle image
donc il fallait le fallait le faire
alors un artisan s'est vu également
remettre la médaille de la
reconnaissance artisanale de l'assemblée
permanente des chambres de métiers de
l'artisanat
j'ai tout cc c'est une récompense
prestigieuse à la sauge ou plus dans la
même cour
la médaille de
de la chambre de métiers c'est
effectivement l'artisan qui se
l'approprient entre guillemets parce
qu'il a été bon et c'est là par contre
ce sont des gens qui ont travaillé pour
les artisans
alors monsieur daniel verlet qui est
l'ancien président de la chambre de
métiers fait depuis de nombreuses années
membre de la chambre de métiers
il a toujours été disponible et donc là
on l'a fait mais il n'y avait pas que
lui il y avait aussi deux agents de la
chambre et ça c'est très très rare pour
leur implication
qui ont été remerciés je crois vous avez
reçu également vous une médaille ça a
été la grosse surprise effectivement je
n'étais pas du tout prévu dans la boucle
si je puis dire donc ça s'est fait dans
mon dos mais j'en remercie effectivement
madame caisse haute et à l'initiative de
cette demande alors rappelle que cet
événement dire se déroulaient aussi dans
cette le cadre de cette semaine de
l'artisanat c'est jusqu'à mercredi un
événement national une grande fête de
l'artisanat
je dirais même que c'est mercredi ça
fait pas la semaine nous allons même
jusqu'à samedi pour il samedi nous avons
des journées portes ouvertes de notre
cfa d'accord que nous modernisons chaque
année un petit peu plus et donc pour
mettre en avant le centre de formation
comme je vous le disais en boucherie en
boulangerie en esthétique en coiffure
voilà déjà les miens justement dans les
yvelines le programme est déclinée il ya
eu je crois que ça a commencé le
week-end dernier il ya ces il ya eu
cette cérémonie hier et donc les portes
le week-end prochain mais comme vous le
disiez tout à l'heure
l'assemblée permanente des chambres de
métiers a décidé ça serait cette semaine
voilà et donc au niveau national partout
dans tous les départements y aura
quelque chose
donc l'objectif de ces semaines vous
l'avez dit c'est mettre en avant un
secteur dont on ne parle pas forcément
assez à votre goût oui en fin de compte
à partir du moment où le l'artisan
s'arrêtent de travailler pour donner du
temps pour faire autre chose il fait pas
de chiffre d'affaires donc à partir de
ce moment là il n'a pas le temps de se
mettre en avant donc nous on est là pour
ça c'est notre job est on est on est là
pour vous mettre en relation si avec eux
d'autres institutions est ce qu'à votre
avis l'artisan jouant un rôle dans la
qualité de vie du français c'est parce
qu'il a un rôle important
je pense qu'effectivement il a un rôle
en été par exemple vous êtes content
d'aller trouver votre bouche et artisans
pour une bonne côte de boeuf ou ce genre
de choses vous êtes content d'aller
chercher une bonne baguette bien cuite
ou alors un coiffeur qui va vous faire
une belle coupe ou alors un maçon qui va
réussir à vous faire un petit mur une
rampe ou voilà donc dans tout dans tous
ses cordes et al aroui effectivement ça
ça procure de bonnes choses à plus d'un
million d'entreprises sont à dans le
secteur de l'artisanat en france 1,3
million pour être exact alors te fais
bien fameux adage quand on répète
souvent c'est que c'est la première
entreprise de france où l'artisanat
est-ce que l'apport de l'artisanat est
considérable à la création de richesses
et d'emplois
mais je pense oui effectivement nous
sommes plus souples que les gros groupes
on va absorber on va s'adapter à toutes
les contraintes qui peuvent nous sortir
tous les jours avec des nouvelles normes
des nouvelles réglementations et donc
oui on est là pour avancer
ça existe et ça fait des centaines
d'années que l'artisan existe nous
sommes là aujourd'hui et nous sommes
certainement là demain et opportunités
terrière sont fort nombreuses à saisir
un énorme
vous allez commencer comme le petit
apprenti effectivement qui sortent de
nos cfa et où d'un certain temps il va
essayer il va être aussi est chef
d'entreprise petites entreprises grosses
entreprises en en c1 mais il va déjà
apprendre le métier et ensuite un beau
jour il va voler de ses propres ailes
merci ronan kerdraon d'avoir été avec
nous merci je rappelle président de la
chambre de métiers et de l'artisanat a
désigné la semaine de l'artisanat un
événement national et qui se déroule
jusqu'à vendredi pour plus
d'informations sur cette semaine est
également sur la chambre de métiers et
l'artisanat vouliez ajouter quelque
chose samedi jusqu'à samedi se prolonge
jusqu'à sa vente ouverte que ya les
jours n'est pas ouvert c'est
effectivement dans s'il vous plaît par
les cfa et donc que vous pouvez vous
rendre sur le site internet de la
chambre des métiers de l'artisanat merci
beaucoup
ce lundi on commémorait le 56e
anniversaire du cessez-le-feu de la
guerre d'algérie la proclamation des
accords d'evian le 19 mars 1962 est mis
fin à huit années de conflit à
guyancourt les élus de la commune et les
anciens combattants se sont réunis pour
se souvenir de cet épisode est michael
et demi d'euros et nicolas landry des
gerbes de fleurs déposées les minutes de
silence
ce lundi soir les élus de la ville de
guyancourt et des anciens combattants de
la guerre d'algérie ont partagé un
moment de recueillement à l'occasion du
56e anniversaire du cessez-le-feu de ce
conflit à l'affrontement qui aura duré
sept ans et tué près de 300 mille
personnes
on y oublie trop trop ceux qui sont
restés là bas c'est pour ça donc on est
quelques-uns y penser mais c'est dans ce
que vous avez vécu cette partie
le cortège s'est rendu dans deux lieux
symboliques de la commune la rue du 19
mars 1962 le monument aux morts objectif
transmettre et partager le souvenir
les commémorations en général elles ont
un aspect pédagogique extrêmement
important alors évidemment la
commémoration du 11 novembre celle du i
mais celle de 2,2 d'aujourd'hui
notamment dans sa dimension
intergénérationnelle de transmission et
c'est pour ça que on y tient très
fortement sur la ville de guyancourt les
commémorations se sont conclus par les
discours et une marseillaise devant les
anciens combattants
[Musique]
on en parle dans un instant en chronique
grosse journée de grève notamment des
cheminots ce jeudi l'une des raisons de
la contestation c'est le projet de
réforme de la sncf voulue par le
gouvernement ce mardi matin une poignée
de militants du parti communiste
français a distribué des tracts en gare
de saint quentin en yvelines une action
en soutien aux cheminots dont le statut
devrait être supprimée par la future loi
est les personnes mobilisées craignent
également que la sncf soit privatisée à
terme
écoutez ses propos recueillis au micro
de michael et me d'euros mais les
usagers du service public et des dangers
qui existent dans le transport parce
qu'on nous présente les cheminots comme
des privilégiés la réalité c'est que les
privilégiés sont au cac 40 ce sont leurs
actionnaires et ce qui est en vue c'est
la privatisation de la sncf et
l'expérience a montré notamment en
angleterre que c'était une catastrophe à
la fois par l'explosion des prix que par
la qualité du service rendu et donc
c'est dans ce sens ça qu'on a besoin
d'une sncf forte et non pas du yen d'une
sncf qui s'affaiblit
comme c'est le cas depuis les
gouvernements précédents aide après les
annonces du gouvernement sur le projet
de réforme du rail pas de privatisation
de la sncf envisagée mais plutôt un
changement de statut elle pourrait
devenir une société anonyme à capitaux
publics une entreprise donc de droit
privé mais dont le capital
appartiendrait entièrement à l'état est
les cheminots qui ne seront pas les
seuls en grève ce jeudi la ratp
l'ensemble des agents de la fonction
publique sont appelés à la mobilisation
ils manifesteront notamment contre le
gel du point d'indicé la restauration du
jour de carence ou encore la suppression
annoncée de 120 mille postes durant le
quinquennat bonsoir à nicolas kirilow
l'histoire et de la rédaction de tv 78
alors en tout sept syndicats de la
fonction publique appellent à la grève
de
nombreuses perturbations sont forcément
à prévoir nicolas est ce qu'on se dirige
vers un jeudi noir alors c'est encore
difficile de s'avancer mais en tout cas
c'est sûr il faudra s'armer de patience
jeudi patience déjà pour les parents
puisque les enseignants sont concernées
par le mouvement qui est lancé
certains cours ne seront pas assurés
c'est certain la ville de plaisir par
exemple indique ce mardi soir que deux
écoles élémentaires seront fermés et
quatre écoles maternelles aussi accueil
perturbé également à magny les hameaux
et la verrière pour certains
établissements selon les informations
dont on dispose encore une fois ce mardi
soir et qui vont probablement évoluer
encore mercredi et jeudi
pour rappel la loi prévoit tout de même
à un service d'accueil minimum mais
celui ci n'est pas toujours assurée pour
des raisons de sécurité ou un manque
d'effectifs pour s'organiser le plus
simple est vraiment de contacter
directement les mairies ou les écoles
pour avoir des précisions à ce propos
sachez aussi que des services de mairie
seront fermés jeudi
si vous avez des démarches
administratives à faire penser à les
décaler des difficultés donc nicolas
dans les écoles mais aussi dans les
transports c'est à prévoir et oui
puisque on en parlait à un instant mais
en plus d en plus des agents de la
fonction publique les cheminots et les
agents de la ratp sont appelés à la
grève jeudi
on ne saura précisément que mercredi
après-midi l'impact du mouvement sur le
trafic en île de france mais localement
on peut déjà indiqué grâce à des sources
syndicales est qu'il ne faudrait compter
qu'un train sur 2 sur la ligne n
entre paris montparnasse et les gares de
saint quentin en yvelines
la ligne ul qui relie la défense
pourrait elle ne pas rouler du tout 0
trains sur cette ligne
l'enjeu en fait est de savoir si les
cadres cheminon vont suivre le mouvement
s'il le suivent alors c'est le scénario
catastrophe pour les usagers
s'il ne le suivent pas il pourrait du
coup on remplacer les grévistes et
assurer un service minimum sur ses
lignes
à noter que la région ile de france a
déjà pris les devants et propose pour
jeudi un service de covoiturage gratuit
pour les voyageurs ou remboursé pour les
conducteurs un service qui pourrait être
utile à l'avenir puisque je vous le
rappelle
les cheminots prévoit de lancer leur
véritable mouvement étalé sur trois mois
à partir du début du mois d'avril
merci nicolas pour ces précisions et
pour rester informer sur vos conditions
de transport consulter régulièrement le
site du transilien qui s'affiche en bas
de l'écran
le département dorénavant implantée au
coeur de saint quentin en yvelines
l'inauguration des nouveaux locaux
regroupant quelques 750 salariés se
dérouler ce mardi matin à l'image de
patrick jacques de dixmude 16 directions
administratives de l'environnement à
l'éducation
regroupés ici au 11 avenue du centre à
guyancourt en plus d'une amélioration
des conditions de travail et l'opération
va permettre aussi de réaliser des
économies selon pierre bédier on les
écoute au micro de wilfrid richy nous
allons céder l'ensemble des propriétés
que nous occupions à versailles et ça
paiera largement le déménagement le coût
du déménagement donc il ya un bénéfice
naturellement le département ne fait pas
de bénéfices donc cet argent gagné sera
réinvesti au service des yvelinois et a
noté le département des yvelines qui
recrutent 145 jeunes pour un emploi
saisonnier à cet été dans le cadre de la
15ème édition est divine étudiants
seniors des visites seront organisées au
domicile des personnes âgées pour rompre
l'isolément et favoriser le lien inter
générationnel et pour plus
d'informations vous pouvez vous rendre
sur le site du conseil départemental lui
justement a dédié sa vie aux autres le
portrait de ce mardi est consacrée à
frédéric pellerin cet habitant des
clayes-sous-bois et de 49 ans a décidé
de créer son entreprise de services à la
personne
une reconversion suite un burn-out la
rencontre est signé patrick jacques de
dixmude et nicolas landry et quentin le
frère bonjour récupérer les clés du
service
merci les clés du service c'est le nom
de l'entreprise créée en janvier 2018
par frédéric pellerin une société de
services à la personne
alors vous venez pour ans alors on va
faire notamment leurs biens
et puis on fera dans la foulée le propre
petit problème dévié
ok ça marche on y va ce jour là michel a
besoin de frédéric notamment pour
intervenir sur la surchauffe de son
ordinateur
donc malgré des montages de
dépoussiérage il a continué à faire du
bruit
d'accord de l'assistance informatique du
ménage du bricolage ou encore du
jardinage différents services à domicile
proposé par frédéric dans différentes
communes autour des clayes-sous-bois ce
que j'ai fait dans un premier temps
c'est que je me suis fait connaître
auprès des associations
enfin les associations ont
principalement de seniors au niveau de
la ville des claies mais pas que ce que
je suis je suis rentré en contact avec
le ccrs donc de la ville d'éclat mais
également de plaisir je suis allé à
wimereux pour me faire connaître
alors monsieur pellerin a déjà été une
personne très agréable à l'heure il est
patient je les utilise pour mes
déplacements je les utilise pour les
petits services comme l'ordinateur et et
l'évier éventuellement si j'ai besoin
d'autres services je contacterai verva à
49 ans frédéric a décidé de se
reconvertir
pendant près de vingt ans il a occupé un
poste de chargé de mission dans une
filiale informatique d'une banque un
métier complet des événements personnels
difficiles les raisons de son burnout un
état d'épuisement professionnel les
entreprises je pense que je suis pas le
seul mais on est bien souvent qu'un
numéro
dans ces fameux numéro où on tient pas
franchement pas pas toujours compte de
l'intérêt de la personne des envies de
la personne de ce que de la personne
peut subir ce qu'elle peut vivre
aidé par sa femme et ses deux filles
frédérique a réussi à tourner la page
avec l'aide de la chambre de commerce de
l'industrie il crée son entreprise en
suivant sa vocation l'envi de se
remettre en question de se rendre utile
de se lever le matin et de deux
avec le smile et non comme une corvée
d'aller bosser deux voilà enfin vraiment
le principe de se rendre utile
d'apporter quelque chose à autrui et
c'est vraiment ce que ce que j'ai envie
de faire et puis ben voilà c'est de se
dire aujourd'hui comme je faire par qui
je vais être appelé
et puis c'est ce sont des petites
satisfaction de voir là bas car tout à
l'heure on a vu madame madame du monde
voilà l'apprécier apprécié que je
l'accompagné il voilà moi c'est ma
satisfaction du jour une satisfaction
qu'il souhaite développer
progressivement il se construit une
clientèle il espère pouvoir toucher un
premier salaire l'année prochaine avec l
horizon les clés du bonheur au travail
on termine ce journal sur une touche de
sourire un festival d'humour du 23 au 30
mars le premier festival le rire soleil
se déroule à buc jouer en josas toussus
le noble et rocquencourt quatre dates au
programme on en parle tout de suite avec
notre invité elle est l'ambassadrice de
ce festival à nice a tenu bon soir si
vous êtes également la directrice du
pôle culture sport et animation pour la
ville de buc alors ce festival est
organisé par l'association rire 78 la
communauté d'agglomération versailles
grand parc la ville de rocquencourt
pourquoi créer un festival du rire sur
plusieurs communes des yvelines alors au
départ c'est un festival qui a déjà eu
en fin qu'elle existe et le festival
d'euros concours festival d'humour qui a
quand même une certaine renommée
puisqu'il a il a été présent pendant une
vingtaine d'années et donc il a vu
passer les plus grands de l'humour et
malheureusement il s'est arrêté je
croyais 2 de deux ans et donc voilà
c'était un festival reconnu intéressant
qui avait cave et une assise vraiment
très très intéressante et donc le
le maire de françois jean-françois
pommery de l'avis de concours a souhaité
qui a soutenu pendant des années donc ce
festival a souhaité lui redonner vie
peut-être sous une forme différente et
donc il a fait appel
avec l'aide de versailles grand parc
donc monsieur de mazières il a fait
appel à eric bouvron donc qui était
directeur artistique de ce festival
pendant un certain temps tout à fait que
dont la renommée n'est plus à faire et
donc il lui a demandé de repenser en
fait un festival mais du coup de lui
donner une une comment dire une une
peut-être humeur voilà une dimension
territoriale
d'où d'ailleurs le nom le rire soleil
pour faire un petit peu clin d'oeil à le
roi soleil donc c'est vraiment le
festival du territoire
le rire c'est le remède à tous les mois
à tous les problèmes oui je pense
qu'aujourd'hui beaucoup de gens en ont
besoin
c'est en même temps c'est on passe des
messages par le rire donc voilà c'est
important aussi de pouvoir donner des
formes différentes au rire puisque
effectivement les gens aujourd'hui la
vie enfin est difficile peut-être pas
mais en tout cas pas fait s'ils aussi
intéressante soit elle et c'est vrai
qu'avec le rire on peut passer beaucoup
de messages non c'est un festival
d'humour qui est tout public mais il ya
tout de même un focus sur les enfants il
ya des ateliers qui sont menées dans les
écoles autour de l'univers de raymond
devos
alors ça c est une caractéristique très
très importante puisque en fait l'idée
c'était aussi d'avoir un volet
pédagogique important et je pense que
c'est un 7-1 c'est un moyen aussi
d'investir sur le jeune public et donc
le public le spectateur de demain comme
le dit si bien
eric bouvron donc c'est important aussi
de fédérer à travers les enfants de de
les éduquer
ajustement à réfléchir à avoir un esprit
critique et donc c'est un travail
l'idée c'était on est aussi soutenue
enfin le faith le festival est soutenu
par la fondation devos et donc c'est un
travail qui se fait dans les écoles avec
toute une toute une panoplie d'artistes
qui viennent sur place dans les écoles
via des ateliers et qui donc travaillent
avec des enfants sur le l'univers de
devos et donc c'est restituer sous des
formes différentes sont en première
partie des représentations qui seront
données dans l'est dans les villes qui
accueillent ce festival soit dans les
écoles mais c'est vrai que cette cette
composante est extrêmement intéressante
et d'ailleurs c'est pour celà enfin nous
en tout cas but qu'on aime beaucoup
travailler avec le jeune public les
enfants etc
ça a été quasiment la première ville à
avoir donné son accord puisque monsieur
le maire est là la maire adjoint délégué
à la culture encourage ce type
d'initiative et veulent justement faire
ce genre de choses a bu que donc nous
avons quasiment été les premiers à dire
oui pour accueillir ce que festive
d'accord alors si on déroule un peu le
programme on va pas dans le tendre tous
déroulés mais c'est en gros la soirée
déjà d'ouverture ce commencera à
toussus-le-noble culturel du vieux
plessis arnaud soirée et xavier vive
sexe un duo comique pourra l'être ce
festival
oui c'est une petite salle but enfin
toussus-le-noble est une petite salle
très intéressante qui donc va accueillir
la première soirée de de ce festival est
donc on espère
en tout cas mobiliser les gens et de
toussus le noble et des villes
environnantes
le vendredi donc le pardon le samedi ça
se passera à buc quand une soirée avec
un plateau d'humoristes voilà de
d'univers différents magicien qui qui
arrivent à réussir tous ces ratages
voilà et et puis le dimanche ça sera
jouée en josas c'est une représentation
donc deux africains très beau spectacle
d'éric nouveau à je viens en josas
et puis la soirée de clôture et c'est
normal se fera un grand concours le 30
mars
et donc il y aura des têtes d'affiché
arnaud cosson qu'on a connues notamment
dans l'émission on n'demande qu'à en
rire voilà sur france 2 voilà agnès pâte
également pour ne pas le citer qu'eux
quelle est l'espérance je vous avais sur
ce premier festival
eh bien écoutez on espère mobiliser
beaucoup de monde
en tout cas en spectateur on essaie de
faire une communication dans ce sens en
c'est vrai qu'un festival qui qui qui se
met en place c'est jamais facile
en tout cas on à l'aide de versailles
grand parc et c'est très appréciable de
même que les villes se mobilisent pour
pour justement essayer de
de le faire connaître c'est vrai que
c'est une programmation enfin en tout
cas ce ce festival est né à un moment où
les villes avaient déjà fait leur
programmation donc ce n'était pas
évident de prendre le train en marche
mais par contre on espère que pour la
deuxième édition qui est donc en cours
de préparation
en tout cas on lance un appel on
aimerait être un peu plus nombreux à
donner vie à ce festival qui serait le
festival du territoire et qui
permettrait également de fédérer et la
programmation vous pouvez la retrouver
sur la page facebook du festival qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran merci alissa
czisny maquis ambassadrice de ce
festival l'humour le rire soleil
merci d'avoir été avec nous voilà c'est
la fin de ce set 8 journal vous pouvez
nous retrouver sur notre site internet
et notre application mobile tv 60,18
belle soirée à tous
[Musique]